I think the thing that I kind of  appreciate more than ever is the  importance in having patience I think  that there's such a tendency especially  in a world where you're able to count  your views in real time that if it  doesn't work today it's never going to  work and you know like I talked to Jimmy  Mr Beast about this a lot and like I  spent whatever seven years making videos  before he had one that broke a thousand  views or something extraordinary like  that and now he's doing a billion views  a month it's extremely unsexy it's  extremely uninteresting and no one wants  to hear that it takes time but it takes  time patience is really the most  undervalued  [Music]  aspect of succeeding in the world of  media today